hey believe nation its Evan my one word
is believe and I believe in you and I
want to see that thing you've got inside
of you come out and have a big impact on
the world I started that meant to me
serious - hang on people who've done
more than us and hopefully we can learn
from them the way they think their
mindsets their beliefs to help us be the
best version of ourselves so today we're
going to learn from David Goggins and
some of his best motivational advice
mentor me David and as always guys as
you're watching if you hear something
that really resonates with you please
leave it down the comments below put
quotes around us or other people can be
inspired as well and when you write it
down it's much more likely to stick with
yourself - joy
[Music]
you
you once said that if you were growing
up in this generation that you would
have a field day because you would take
their souls what did you mean by that
the younger generation quits not
everybody so I got it I got put that
people get too butthurt so not everybody
most of this generation quits the second
they get talked to you did this wrong
you did this wrong or they get yelled at
it's so easy to be great nowadays
because everybody else is most people
are weak this this is a softened
generation so if you have any mental
toughness any of any ability you have
any fraction of self-discipline the
ability to not want to do it but still
do it people have a hard thing
understand I hate to run and what makes
me so crazy it doesn't anymore
pickle why did you run if you hate it
what are you talking about I want to
take showers and eat either I hate that
too that the whole that's a life man
that and it wasn't until I changed that
mentality that I became somebody I hated
going to school so I guess when I was
dumbest that's what will one plus one is
two
but if you can get through to doing
things that you hate to do on the other
side is greatness that's what people are
saying by me running I encounter in my
mind I'm not training for a race I'm
training for life I'm training for the
time when I get that two o'clock in the
morning call that my mom is dead or
something happens tragic in life I don't
fall apart I'm training my mind in my
body my spirit so it's all one so I can
handle what life is gonna throw at me
because the life I've lived it throws a
whole bunch at you and if you're not
physically immensely prepared for that
you're just gonna crumble and you're
good for nobody talk to me about what it
takes to be on one side of a door in
Iraq or anywhere knowing on the other
side of the door people who are not
afraid of you they're ready for you to
come in and you still have and they have
guns and you still have to breach that
door
that's a great question it that's a very
scary situation when you are on one side
of the door and your mind is racing
because on the other side of that door
it could be no one it could be four guys
with four ak-47s that that door you're
about to open can be booby-trapped
so once you open it boom your legs are
gone so there's a thousand things you
think about when you're the first guy
second guy third guy getting ready going
a room and flood it and that's what I
talk about the warrior mentality and
that's why so many people are lost when
I start talking you have the right
you're lucky that you don't have to
think like warriors think you're very
privileged I chose this world to be a
warrior
and I would choose it again if I came
back to this world but the mentality of
a warrior is very different than normal
mentality you must be that person on
that door Oh get ready to open it
thinking to yourself if I die so be it
the only way you can go in that door is
no there's a great chance you're gonna
die it's like being a seal you train
with live ammo you jump on an airplane
every everything you do you could die so
to be a warrior why people don't
understand me I'm glad you don't
understand me Merry Christmas good on
you because being a warrior takes a
whole different mindset a whole
different mindset to know that there's a
great chance I may not be in like I was
in for 21 years I'm lucky I'm very lucky
that I'm alive able to talk to you able
to still run but when you sign up on
that dotted line to be a set like a seal
your mentality changes I may not live
you got accept that and that's the
mentality you have and that's what makes
you a warrior if you're scared to die
you're a bad warrior I hate it jumping
out of airplanes I hated shooting guns I
hate it the job as a Navy SEAL but I did
it because I wanted to change myself
everything I do I'm not really
comfortable
doing but if you choose to go that route
to go be a Navy SEAL you might as well
go be the hardest in the world because
if you're choosing to do something you
have two routes you can go there and be
a little a little weak person and get
through barely and that's your
reputation or you can go through the
hardest guide you can possibly be a nice
reputation so my whole thing is if
you're gonna choose to open that door in
Iraq or Afghanistan open them go in hard
because they're gonna remember you by
slowly opening and peeking in so if
you're gonna open it and you made the
mind open it don't crack it open open
the door go in that's with life if
you're chewing to do if you're choosing
to do something attack it because
they're gonna remember you as not
attacking it so I want to be remembered
you can hate me but one thing you can't
say about me I didn't attack it so
that's them attire you have if you're
gonna do something you might as well
attack it because you do it anyway right
do you use that in civilian life like do
you still employ though I'm gonna attack
it I'm gonna take their souls like how
does that play out in a non-combat zone
it still works for me in in life as far
as attacking things because uh no matter
what I wanted you no matter what Avenue
I choose I want to be the very best and
the very best may not be I'm number one
the very best is did I leave everything
inside of me out there so attacking it's
not like I want to win this or win that
or be the best the best is I'm running
against myself and everything I do and
that's and that's what I attack I attack
myself I'm always questioning myself I'm
always holding myself accountable before
I start a race I actually imagine myself
going through all those checkpoints I'm
imagining all these different emotions
and things I'm gonna go through so when
it happened
it just flows all this imagery is so
important in life if you can see
yourself doing something you can do it
if you can't see yourself doing it
usually you can't achieve it
everybody said get into I hit a wall in
a race that's so long if you hit several
walls and every time you hit a wall it's
a big deciding factor in that race or in
your life if you're not running and you
have a decision to make
you can stop at that wall you can go
parallel left or parallel right you're
looking for that door and when you get
to the door you have no decision to make
should I open it or should I keep it
closed if you keep it closed you made
the decision to quit if you open that
door you made decisions to carry on and
continue on with your journey or your
mission wherever you're on and I always
open that door because once you open the
door and you go through it your mind
resets and it gets you a few more miles
I came to describe it to you how how you
feel when you know you're gonna complete
the hardest thing they're done your life
the second you realize not give up your
body gets back in tune again and you're
ready to go I have those mental blocks
all through the race but that's when I
smile too I signed up for that race to
see what kind of citizen I'm gonna make
and that's why I do it
and usually it's the season to keep on
going forward I have to experience life
and that's how I experience life David
tell him about the cookie jar the cookie
jar is something I invented as you all
know your mom has a cookie jar and
sometimes you might have an Oreo
sometimes you might have a chips of
Hawaii sometimes you might have a
Oakland raisin cookie
you never know just in there my cookie
jar has every single failure and success
of my life sup my overcame so what
happens in this in time of life when
you're stressed out and things get bad
even the hardest guy in the world me
everybody thinks and I think I'm the
hardest guy in the world you got to
believe that you got believe you are
something I will in my mind reach into
my cookie jar and sometimes you forget
how hard you are in times of need
because you're you're stressed but you
forget I'm a Navy SEAL I'm a ranger I'm
that but you forget all that cuz your
life sucks I calm down take that one
second get control of my life
reaching the cookie jar well you got
called [ __ ] your whole life and you're
now the only person histories you just
dissing this put it back in the cookie
jar reset my mind you have to remind
yourself of how badass you really are in
times of need
that's the cookie jar my biggest advice
to give everybody in the world is like I
say we live in an external world
everything is is you got to see it touch
it it's external if you can for the rest
of your life live inside of yourself
stop listening to people who are calling
you fat gay transsexual [ __ ]
everything that is makes no sense all
these insecure people put their
insecurities on you you gotta flush it
out you got to just be whoever the hell
God or whatever the hell you believe in
if you believe in nothing but yourself I
don't care what it is you're gonna take
everything and throw it away you have to
believe in one thing and that is
yourself and and I'm not saying don't
believe in God are what you believe in
but right now for you to find greatness
in yourself you're not gonna find it by
looking in a book or by even hearing me
I may give you the spark but you've got
to go inside yourself to find it and
that means you gotta be quiet shut the
[ __ ] up go in a room stop talking search
your soul search your mind search your
abilities and you'll find it but if
you're not looking for it you won't find
it so you got to go start your journey
and the journey starts with you finding
why the hell am I here on this planet
Earth why am I here if you don't know
that you will live the rest your life
searching always asking the question why
everybody's journey is different
everybody's journey is different I was
on a journey to see who David Goggins
was and that journey took me in some of
the hardest areas a human being can even
imagine and right now at 41 I'm the
happiest person on the planet because
you know I had a climb on every several
times just to look down on my life to
see what hell I came from and that's
what kept me going through all this
stuff like I I am vision myself going
through like when I was a young kid and
they called me [ __ ] all-time that got
my dad beat the hell out of me and I was
have no self-esteem I had this vision of
if I can make it to where I want to go
imagine when I look back on my damn life
how proud I will be and now I'm here and
I'm able to look back on this life I
lived that many people will never
understand because why when you're
passionate they think you're crazy and
you can't even explain to people why
you're doing or why you did what you did
because you found your purpose and once
you find your purpose you can't really
explain it to normal people because they
don't understand passion because they
live everyday life that's going not
really finding their purpose so I become
a foreign language to people I think so
they put me a category of your this
crazy no no no no I'm passionate I found
my purpose in this life
[Music]
when you think that you are done
do only 40 percent into what your by is
capable of doing and that's just a limit
there that we pour ourselves
[Music]
got our leader of the 150-mile coming in
[Applause]
you never get really to know how I feel
I never really tell you the truth I'm
always gonna feel good I want to feel
and show you no weakness gratulations
like thanks a lot man hundred fifty mile
champion first place new course record
way to go graduation I'm never happy and
satisfied with one thing I do is always
a continuous journey and in all my races
there's never in its kind of fall in
together it's like one big journey that
that won't inside I'd thank you guys so
much for watching I hope you enjoyed I'd
love to know what did you take from this
video what was the single most important
message that you are going to
immediately apply somehow to your life
or to your business leave it down in the
comments below I look forward to hearing
what you have to say I also want to give
a quick shout to surge wisdom thank you
so much I'm picking up a copy of my book
your one word and doing the review on
your youtube channel I really really
really appreciate it
and I'm so glad you enjoyed the book
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
[Music]
the most important work ever if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
so it would be like a little beacon
table ignition if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details
[Music]